everyone I'm Ilana and welcome to my
channel where today I wanted to talk
about Joker I want to start this video
by saying that I really liked the movie
I thought it was beautifully shot
I thought Joaquin Phoenix's performance
is one of the best that I've ever seen
he embodied the character so fully down
to every movement down to how distorted
and depraved he looked even in scenes
that were completely silent I thought
his performance was phenomenal I really
liked the score there there's a lot of
dialogue that I liked I enjoyed watching
Joker for all of those reasons like good
cinematography there's a lot of things
that I can praise it for I do think it's
an incredible piece of cinematography
especially when I walked out of the
cinema the person I was with us so what
did you think and I think my answer was
I don't know and I've seen a lot of
people have a similar reaction where I
needed a few days to continue thinking
about it before I really settled on what
the one thing that I didn't like was or
why I wasn't sure how I felt about it
after I'd finished watching it so to cut
to the point basically I think that I
have issues with the plot with office
motives with what the movie is supposed
to be and I don't know how to stop okay
so I tweeted just a few hours ago saying
solely because I'm interested to see how
diverse the responses are and the
diversity of interpretation it's one of
my favorite things about the movie in a
sentence what do you think jerk is about
other than just a bad man who becomes
worse man a lot of responses including
titties of which I did not see that many
but for the most part people are saying
mental illness it's about society
shortcomings a screen representation of
how mental illness if left unchecked can
twist reality to make that action seem
justifiable again just a lot of people
saying someone who is mentally sick who
is then isolated and becomes awful but
there are also a lot of other opinions
that I got as replies to this I think
the meaning of the film isn't consistent
based on people's interpretations I
think walking Phoenix said that that was
an intentional thing they wanted you to
be able to interpret it however you
wanted and I understand that but it is
also my least favorite thing about it
basically the issues I have with this
film that I feel like it doesn't commit
to anything
and the one thing that I think is
bothering a lot of critics of this film
is that it feels empty and it feels
pointless to certain groups of people
again it's the people who are looking
for this particular thing in it because
it doesn't commit to anything and I do
not think it commits the idea of mental
health and the main reason that I think
that is this one thing just this one
thing if they hadn't written this one
particular thing I might feel totally
completely differently but I feel like
it's such a huge writing floor that just
throws the whole like it's a movie about
mental illness and how we need to take
it more seriously and how we need to
fund it like I would buy that if they
hadn't just made this one thing clear
completely shadows that idea for me I
could fully get into this movie being
about that but they okay the thing when
author is on his medication he openly
says all I have a negative thoughts he's
miserable the minute he stopped taking
his medication he's happy if the message
is that we need to support the mentally
ill and we need to make sure that they
have funding why would you then go and
make offer
happy and more confident and start
getting noticed as soon as he stops
getting help of course that makes sense
for the Joker I get it but it means that
that through-line are you telling me
that this movie is some kind of
commentary on mental health just
completely falls apart for me because as
soon as his mental health was being
ignored by society we see he is happier
he becomes a more realistic version of
himself he is more confident he becomes
happy he starts getting the things that
he wants and so that through-line is
completely lost for me I wish that they
hadn't done that if he had never been
medicated I probably would have been
able to buy it but regardless I do think
this is intentional
this movie is pretty clearly inspired by
movies like the king of comedy and taxi
driver which are movies that take
stances taxi driver if you haven't heard
of it is a movie
honestly extremely similar in a lot of
voice about a guy who's an outcast in
society who drives a cab for a living
who likes a girl takes her on a date
that was ultimately a bad call and then
loses her affection who watches an awful
city with awful things happen in it and
tries to take a stand but the difference
is that taxi driver is more of the rise
of a vigilante you're watching someone
see society be awful see how terrible
people can be and watch something fall
apart and try to fix it in an
inappropriate way because it's the best
way he knows how that movie I understand
what it is about I get taxi drivers
point he becomes sort of a Batman in
this instance and that's another thing
that Joker doesn't even commit to is the
idea that society is bad or the upper
class versus lower class again would be
a point that I could buy into but they
never actually show it all of the stuff
to do with the upper class and the lower
class in Joker said to you over the
radio you don't actually see any of it
it is just constantly telling you rather
than showing you which is against that
good idea of writing shalt not tell it
is only ever telling you about this
class disparity that has displaced
people it never actually puts that in
practice and shows us what that is like
it shows us what the elite are doing
outside of Thomas Wayne kind of being a
dick it just doesn't commit to that idea
in a way that a movie like taxi driver
does it's like you tried to make a taxi
driver or you tried to make a king of
comedy but you couldn't quite make
either of those because you knew that it
was going to be extremely broad in terms
of who saw it if you commit to any
statement if you commit to it being a
criticism of how we treat the mentally
ill in society which I don't think it
does I think people just want that to be
in that movie I think in terms of plot
that is poorly written if that
what this film is trying to say it can't
do that because that could ostracize
part of the tremendously enormous DC
audience it's still a joka film the
highest points of this movie the things
that actually made me feel something
we're still always related to Batman I
think it's so cool that the day where
you see you know off the leading up to
finally solidly becoming joka happens to
be the same day where you would see the
beginning of Bruce Wayne starting to
become Batman then lining those two
things up is so cool but it's not cool
because of the way that movie did it
it's cool because we know who Batman is
and we know what Gotham is and we know
who Joker is and we know what that means
and I think because this is still a DC
movie it's extremely restricted in terms
of what kind of comments it could make
in committing to it being about mental
illness in committing to it being about
empathy or isolation I don't think it
plays into any of those things and it is
inspired by a lot of things that have
real impact a really good example is
when office shoots the men on the
platform that is absolutely inspired by
in 1984 shooting let me pull that up the
1984 New York City subways shooting on
December 22 1984 for African American
teenagers Barry Allen Troy County
Darrell KB and James Ramshaw was shot
and wounded by Bernhard goats on a New
York City subway train in Manhattan I
may have butchered everyone's names he
surrended to the police nine days later
and was charged with attempted murder
assault and reckless endangerment and
basically it came out that he thought
that they were going to rob him what
they want this is setting a really
similar time and when it happened
it I mean it says it here it's booked
nationwide debates on race and crime in
major cities the legal limits of
self-defense and the extent to which
citizenry could rely on the police to
secure their safety they cold go at the
subway vigilante and he was both praised
and vilified in the media and public
opinion for what he did it feels like
it's very clearly based off of that
thing they basically just tried to
switch the race issues for class issues
which
again you can't really buy into because
you never actually see any of the class
issues in Gotham you hear that people
are upset you hear that there are things
going on in Gotham where the lower-class
are being mistreated but it never
explains how or why or what those things
are other than super rats I think it's
basically just in synopsis it's a movie
I really like right this is
intentionally a video that I am making
to criticize one thing in a movie that I
otherwise enjoy and praise so this is
like not me saying this movie is [ __ ]
because of this I'm totally not doing
that this is literally me focusing on
one thing that I didn't like and I think
also just trying to explain why some of
the other people who've said that they
have found the movie pointless or
directionless or unmotivated might feel
that way but I do not want people to get
confused and be like you hate this film
why did you shut up whatever not what
I'm saying just focusing on one
criticism and I want to see more
passionate about the criticism because I
like the movie as a whole we tend to
criticize the things we like but it for
sure made me feel devoid of anything I
didn't
it was more like watching pretty things
on a screen than experiencing a story
for me because I expected which is maybe
my own fault the critical or social
commentary that would come with a major
class issue that would come with mental
health funding being cut and seeing the
repercussions of that for a person which
you would expect to be negative but I'll
positive with seeing a movie
clearly mimic the New York subway
shooting or clearly mimicked taxi driver
or the King of Comedy but never commit
to any of those things or any of the
things those things permitted - does
that make sense it's like it just
doesn't latch on to any of the ideas and
doesn't have a consistent theme and
because it doesn't commit to one thing
and tries to appeal to everyone it means
that a lot of us are enjoying it but I
think for the people who were looking
for slightly more of a purpose I feel
like a lot of people are trying to push
purpose onto it rather than taking
purpose away from it and in fact is it's
okay every movie doesn't have to have a
moral it doesn't have to have a me
it doesn't have to stand for anything or
make any commentary it totally doesn't
have to do that I think just for some
movie-going audiences if that particular
thing was jarring either because of an
expectation well because we like plots I
just read over the plot to make sure I'm
not missing anything the literal plot
and description here and yes it's it's
more like a series of events than a
story basically and I think this is not
because of anything to do with Joaquin
Phoenix who was incredible don't think
it's anything to do with politics or
sjw's or whatever arguments are gonna
break out in the comments here that I'm
not looking forward to I think it's just
because it was a DC movie it had to
appeal to so many goddamn people because
Batman is one of the biggest pop culture
icons ever and that's a really hard
thing to do so they basically made a
character study it was brilliantly acted
that doesn't feel complete as a
character study to me because he's
unmotivated honestly it's just um I feel
like it's just the writing for me was
underwhelming and again this isn't a
thing that I even feel that strongly
about cuz it took me days to realize
this but I mean if you haven't seen it
you probably shouldn't have watched this
video frankly but I still highly
recommend seeing I'm going to see it
again I'm really looking forward to
seeing it again I think that I will be
thinking about this movie for a really
long time and I'm so glad that it exists
in part because of that but that is it
for me today everyone excited to discuss
this with you guys as well see how
people feel about it but overall movie I
really enjoyed that I think was held
back by the fact that it was a DC movie
but all the coolest stuff that happens
it's still related to Batman well so why
did he get in the fridge
I still haven't figured that out can
someone tell me why you got in the
fridge